welcome back to new rock stars
spider-man no way home just revealed a
new scene described by tom holland as
having a jaw-dropping mystery cameo that
could be anyone from tobey maguire to
maurice the chicken pig of shanghai
we are gonna deduce who it is and why it
is methysto i'm just kidding or am i
yes i'm just kidding this is inside
marvel our weekly deep dive into the
biggest marvel news we have a lot to
talk about this week i'm eric voss here
to go through it all with me is mt how
you doing mt i'm feeling good man but
i'm also feeling very intrigued about a
certain uh quote by tom holland recently
hmm yeah yeah we're going to talk all
about it this week with these new
details we've learned from the empire
magazine insightful feature on
spider-man no way home a little later
this episode we're also going to talk
about kevin feige's secret battle plan
in 2014 to convince sony to deal them in
on the spider-man character
and what that tells us about no way home
as well as we're gonna talk about
whether critics are being fair or unfair
on eternals okay thoughts there as
someone who's able to see it early spicy
topics eric i'm very gonna spill some
tea we got some tea we're gonna spill it
uh but before we get into all that we
want you to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com grab the latest
obsession shirt inspired by shangchi the
great protector uh it's a limited supply
shirt with a dwindling number left in
this universe so grab one now or live
the rest of your life without some great
protection
head over to new rockstarsmerch.com to
support the channel and get yourself
some great gear
uh we also have this new spider-man
shirt that i'm loving right now and i'm
wearing an honor and
conversation on spider-man so a lot of
great options a lot of great options but
mt what's our what's our big question
that we're gonna lead off with this week
well eric we gotta talk about it okay
because who is the new mystery cameo in
spider-man no way home teased by mr tom
holland himself because
i i just need to know who is this man
why is he so excited yeah
let's figure it out together uh in
empire magazine's upcoming issue all
about spider-man no way home tom holland
revealed that he filmed one of the
coolest scenes he has ever shot his
words
uh that is gonna feature peter parker
aunt may happy hogan and one mystery
character i'm gonna read you his quote
he says it's four people sitting at a
table having a conversation about what
it's like to be a superhero and it's
amazing the other day we watched the
scene my brother and i and our jaws were
on the floor
seems like an uncomfortable position to
watch a movie or a movie scene just sit
in a chair you don't have to have your
jaws on the floor
i'm a literalist and that's how i read
everything um
yeah he would and we wouldn't be able to
see him he would just be there right he
would just physically observe him
absolutely invisible
but munching on those chips
louder it's a wrestling thing i think
they teach you that the wwe it's just
like how to be right a lot of people can
be uh
exactly um
so uh tom holland's brother is harry
holland and he actually worked as a pa
on the set of far from home and since
playing a small role in holland's film
cherry uh harry has been rumored to play
a role in no way home maybe as someone
who robs the store that peter burger
oils that hasn't been confirmed it's
just a rumor um but let's just imagine
this scene based off what holland has
told us we got four characters peter
parker aunt may happy hogan and someone
else someone jaw-dropping to look at
later on as you're watching this scene
uh and they're sitting around a table
and they're talking about what it's like
to be a superhero
so that could mean a lot of things right
it could mean this mystery character is
themselves a superhero and is mentoring
peter parker and how to balance his
personal life with being a superhero uh
it also could be at a several different
points in the movie um you could imagine
this maybe being earlier in the movie
when peter's still kind of dealing with
the fallout of his being exposed by
mysterio and uh aunt may and happy hogan
they're all just still kind of figure
out the next steps for peter from a
legal standpoint
um but your mind first goes to candidate
one
tobin mcguire peter parker and candidate
two andrew garfield peter parker both of
whom went through that whole process in
their own universes you know balancing
their personal life trying to maintain
that secret but i would argue to a
lesser degree than the tom holland peter
parker has gone through in his movies
homecoming far from home and then even
to a smaller extent infinity war and end
game the moment on the school bus and
then when peter parker comes back to his
school and end game like they've been
really focused on keeping peter parker
in the era of being a
teenager in his high school balancing
that whole side of his life um so it
kind of seems to me that he would have
more to explain to toby maguire peter
parker and andrew garfield peter parker
how to balance the life of of a
superhero than they would be able to
tell him but what do you think of t
oh man i really do
think that this is 100 toby mcguire or
peter parker i mean for me anyway
because like oh okay let's start 100
confident because like
toby maguire's peter parker had such a
huge role in superhero movies in general
and like that spider-man one changed the
game and so i think that tom holland was
probably just watching the scene of him
sitting next to toby mcguire and just
like oh man like i am the new person in
the suit i inherited the mantle so i
feel like he was just like really
freaked out just like really just happy
and grateful for the moment which i
would be too because like that's nuts um
so yeah i think that toby maguire would
have a lot to teach this younger peter
parker who was still in his high school
years because you know we left well we
last left toby mcguire i was like you
know this older guy he was an older man
in spider-man 3 and like he was just
like sort of doing his whole college
thing so like he has at this point who
knows how long he's lived and like what
kind of things he's gone through so he
probably has so much to teach this tom
holland peter parker so he does
he he does and especially if you look at
what he went through in spider-man 2 in
2004 when he uh gave up being uh
spider-man um and in spider-man 3 how
he's dealing with his relationship with
mary jane and balancing his own
selfishness with his own career there's
there is a lot to learn there i want to
go to another suspect though maybe tom
hardy eddie brock venom because it looks
like he may be coming into this film
coming out of venom let there be carnage
that whole post-credits scene um and a
lot of the moments in venom let there be
carnage where venom and eddie were
debating how much of a lethal protector
to be
uh which seems to
thematically at least fit in directly
with what peter's going through in no
way home of being this kind of vigilante
but being a protector of the city but
one who was viewed at as being a lethal
one
um and uh we just it seems like one that
tom holland might know about but want to
keep under wraps for now but there's
another reason why i think um
venom could be the candidate here but i
wanna also remind us that happy and aunt
may are there right so why did they need
to be in this scene and you could maybe
look at it from the perspective of maybe
this cameo is going to be someone who is
questioning peter about his actions as a
superhero either like from a legal
standpoint so that brings in the option
of charlie cox is matt murdock
who could be not an attorney sitting
around a table right like you kind of
imagine an interrogation room or some
kind of legal boardroom or something
like that um but i also want to throw at
you uh tatiana maslany as jennifer
walters she hulk who we're gonna learn a
lot more about in mid-november at this
disney plus day
uh and i think like we may finally get
some little teases to her and her
upcoming disney plus series early 2022.
uh
maybe she as a prosecuting attorney is
interrogating peter parker
i do like that because like jennifer
walters is coming in like it would make
sense to introduce her now in this
scenario where peter parker is in really
hot water so yeah oh my god that would
be so great if it was jennifer walters
but i really do going back to the venom
thing i would love if it was just like
just venom like venom the symbiote if
having the conversation not eddie i just
i just don't want any of this
conversation just venom should be like
oh yeah this is great being a lethal
protector it's like i just think all the
time it's great
yeah i think that that could more likely
be the case um let's also talk about jk
simmons as jay jonah jameson who we
already know is going to be in this
movie as the host of the daily bugle but
imagine this table like if you're going
to watch like what's an exciting version
of a table conversation what about one
that is on the set of his news show like
an interview table as he is being
grilled by j jonah jameson happy hogan
uh aunt may are there as support to
peter parker he's like well you have
like you know someone who represents the
the stark uh corporation someone who is
kind of his paternal guardian uh and
they're there to show support and jay
jonah jameson is just chewing him out
for ratings oh well that makes so much
sense considering that peter parker is a
minor so like that makes
so much sense for actually because his
mom is his mom his aunt may would be
there and happy would definitely be
there so yeah j jones jameson makes a
lot of sense because people are excited
about that he's also a very classic
character he's a timeless character in
the whole raimi spider-man mythos so
yeah and you picture jaw on the floor
peter parker watching this back
yeah i'm going through all the options
right now so i'm going to give you my
percentage ratings of who i think is
most likely the least likely but i want
to give another suspect here
uncle ben parker someone we have not yet
seen in the mcu someone they teased in
each of the the homecoming and then in
the far from home um and the the
jaw-dropping aspect of it is whoever
they cast to play this role it could be
anybody you know like there's lots of
fun actors out there it'd be exciting to
see um and or maybe just someone who's
brought back to life through whatever
multiversal means
uh and they're here now to advise and
counsel peter you know drop that great
line with great power comes great
responsibility i hope it's steve carell
i really want to steve carrell uncle ben
let's get it marty i think that would be
exciting
yeah so now just to remind everyone in
the rainy films cliff robertson played
uncle ben he has passed away he died in
2011. uh in the mark webb films the
great martin sheen president bartlett
played uncle ben um now aunt may is
marissa tomei in the mcu she's a bit
younger you know hot aunt uh that could
mean that the uncle ben of the mcu could
be a bit younger as well and now marisa
tomei is 56 years old currently she was
what around 48 uh when she played uh
aunt may in captain america civil war
when they shot that movie not when it
came out um so this uncle ben would have
died even before that so he could
conceivably be someone in his 40s given
like what we know about what tony
stark's visit to peter parker during
civil war i think that uncle ben
probably died somewhat very like very
shortly before civil war because that's
when peter parker started becoming
spider-man so yeah i think that yeah
peter parker i think it's civil war said
that he got the bite six months before
that so it was around like the christmas
before civil war so he would have yes
sometime between that uh maybe a couple
months before the events of civil war is
when uncle ben would have died let's go
back to what tom holland said about this
scene this is a scene that he would have
already shot so he's describing watching
back that scene at a later point with
his brother maybe during a screening or
when they watch the dailies of it like
they're watching after some work has
been done on it and then that experience
of watching it is what he described as
jaw-dropping so that would mean that
what makes this scene so insane is how
it all comes together in post-production
with like editing with visual effects so
the question is really what new
surprises would shock tom holland beyond
what he already experienced shooting
that scene himself sitting across the
table from someone he already first
acted out the scene with on the set
so that would suggest that this mystery
character might have some kind of
fantastical quality to them that can
only be brought to life in
post-production and viewed later so uh
we have suggested dr strange in this
movie might be being manipulated by some
external threat probably not mephisto i
don't think that's the case
don't make fun of me for that or make
fun of me for it i don't care i just
want you to imagine briefly scarlet
witch in all of her glory right her
mysticism swirling everything all right
got you and the table is like a seance
table like something in her
ouija board we got a ouija board yeah
right acting uncles
[Laughter]
yes
i'm at spider-man 3 now uncle ben i wish
you could see
can you hear us uncle ben
yes or no
your wife is still as hot as ever
they do like a whoopi goldberg and ghost
scene where
where marissa tobi
i was thinking like happy and marissa
told me and like uncle ben just like
oh this just got really uncomfortable
um
now to uh on on that vein other
sorcerers like agatha harkness or loki
you know we've heard some rumors that
loki could show up in in multiverse of
madness act the hardness i hope shows up
in multiverse and madness um and then if
you talk about characters who would be
enhanced via vfx she-hulk does come back
as an option right in that regard but i
think based on all this if they are
sitting around a table talking about
being a superhero with some kind of
jaw-dropping vfx slay added later after
the principal shoot a character that has
not yet been confirmed to be in the
movie but tom holland might know about
and not want to reveal
i think going through the options you
said 100
at the first uh
i think i'm at like maybe like 15
likelihood that it's peter parker 50
likelihood or a toby 50 that it's andrew
garfield
um maybe uh uh 20
that it is like some other um mystical
character like scarlet witch or regular
darkness or loki uh 20
that it is an attorney character uh like
um charlie cox matt murdocker or
jennifer walters and whatever percentage
is left over let's say 20 20. one plus
two plus one plus one uh uh thirty
thirty three so about thirty percent
likely i think it's tom hardy as eddie
brock venom and i think it's either
going to be fully venom or that weird
kind of like backpack version of venom
that he had and let there be target
you know what after this conversation i
am no longer 100 all right i'm gonna say
70
toby i would say 70 toby 10
um to jj 10 to venom and then 10
to
what was the other one that we said [ __ ]
jj venom and um uh uncle ben yes or like
a uncle ben cytonario um yeah i would
love if it was um
if it was just like somehow a robert
downey junior spider-man variant that
would be amazing oh yeah yeah we're
going to road options here
uh i mean my rogue option always has to
be mephisto right it's just like yes
dirty ass
mud man mephisto
a little girl from one more day just a
little girl being like i can help you
daddy
this superhero she's jump roping
it's just like the shining
oh my god please i hope it's a little
girl now i just yeah i forgot to include
in my percentages everything i just said
about um about jay jonah jameson or uh
or uncle ben just take their percentages
away from my uh toby mcguire andrew
garfield i think that it's likely that
they're going to be in this movie i just
think i don't think that meeting seems
going to be around a table i think
that's going to be reserved for someone
else
a bigger table
yes a bigger table it's like me a table
it's going to be like uh less oppressive
they're all gonna sit around in a circle
of chairs and just kind of like share
and they're gonna share like oh you know
tom uh peter tom peter you haven't
shared today i don't wanna share it
and andrew garfield's like good i want
to talk more
i would love if they all had name tags
and they all had peter parker on the
planet
it serves no purpose at all
serves no purpose all right well we're
going to discuss whether eternals
deserves its mixed rotten tomatoes score
and kevin feige's secret battle plan
against sony uh but first we want to
thank some people who helped us make
this episode there's one kind of cameo
that none of us want in a movie in our
lives a cameo from a big old credit card
balance well upstart can help lift that
burden and help you avoid that pesky
intruder upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income and employment history that
means they can offer smarter rates with
trusted partners with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars you can
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts we determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel
and our friends at audible would like to
remind you to listen to the sandman act
two on audible the next part to the
number one new york times bestseller the
sandman is available for your listening
pleasure right now enter the dreaming
again and journey into a world of myths
imagination and terror based on the dc
graphic novels written by the great neil
gaiman the epic voice cast is led by
james mcavoy as morpheus lord of dreams
and includes brian cox kat dimmings john
lithgow jeffrey wright and so many more
the blockbuster audio adaptation of the
greatest epic in the history of comic
books continues and expands into the
french revolution ancient rome 19th
century san francisco 8th century
baghdad and beyond it's never only a
dream go to audible.com dreaming and
listen now and we all sometimes lose
sleep binging a show but you shouldn't
lose any sleep because of a bad mattress
well helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress and i love it the
quiz matched me with a medium firm
mattress with lumbar support that sleeps
cool the mattress ships right to your
door for free no need to go to a
mattress store just go to helixsleep.com
insidemarvel take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to the
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com
inside marvel and halloween is right
around the corner that means it's time
to watch some scary movies and there's
no better place to do that than on
shudder than netflix of horror you can
stream great thrillers horror and
suspense for 5.99 a month or 56.99 a
year shutter has the largest fastest
growing curated selection of thrilling
and dangerous entertainment stream on
apple and android xbox or however you
watch your content it's ad free and they
have an excellent mix of classics new
stuff and some unexpected surprises all
presented in an uncluttered interface
around the office we all have our
favorites on the platform including
train to busan mandy the whaling and the
classic poltergeist which we actually
watched last year on a new rockstar's
retreat in october oh it was a wonderful
experience so they have a great
collection of exclusive and original
programming our editor drew is a huge
fan of the joe bob briggs last drive-in
series i gotta check that one out uh so
get started streaming on the best horror
thriller in supernatural content
shutter's expertly curated collection
includes must-see titles like vicious
fun the mortuary collection and pg
psycho gorman plus all the great horror
documentaries and hit creep show tv
series from the executive producer greg
nicotero the walking dead so try shutter
free for 30 days go to shutter.com use
the promo code rogue that's
s-h-u-d-d-e-r-dot-com
and promo code rogue all right mt back
to the big marvel news this week what's
next well we gotta talk about this
because what was kevin feige's secret
plan to convince sony to share
spider-man with marvel like what was
that all about a new book called the
story of marvel studios the making of
the marvel cinematic universe by tara
bennett and paul terry reveals how in
spring 2014 kevin feige actually
assembled a secret retreat among marvel
studios top execs to put together a
battle plan ahead of a meeting with sony
for spider-man stories now in the mcu so
sony's amazing spider-man 2 starring
andrew garfield came out in may 2014 it
underperformed a bit and then shortly
after sony had amy pascal invited kevin
feige to a lunch meeting to discuss some
story ideas for a third film now i've
talked about this a little bit on the
channel before it would have been kind
of crazy there was some talk about um
using norman osborne's cloning and
regeneration technology that would have
tried to like either clone or regenerate
gwen stacy for the movie uh like there
was a part where norman osborne dies in
that movie and they scan his bed and
there's like a cooler on uh on a cart uh
and yeah they were gonna try to like
regenerate him and keep his head in a
cryogenic chamber there was gonna be
some crazy [ __ ] in that movie
in addition to some sinister six stuff
but yeah it was gonna be wild and you
can imagine kevin feige i mean i think
there was a sony leak and he had some
notes on spider-man 2.
uh yeah you can go look up all of that
on your own but according to this book
they gave us some new information that
apparently a few days ahead of their
lunch kevin feige scrambled together an
impromptu mini creative retreat with
their core creative producers if there
were even the slightest chance peter
parker could be part of the mcu feige
wanted to have the bones of a battle
plan already figured out with no time to
spare feige announced an
all-hands-on-deck situation every
executive producer at marvel studios had
to be part of a secret two-day-long
off-site retreat held in a rented hotel
space in santa monica no one else at
marvel studios was told about what they
were doing just that it was quote a get
together
in that closed room two questions were
posed if there were an opportunity to
broker some kind of deal with sony how
would it work and if they leveraged
something like a five picture deal what
stories would they want to tell one
thing they all quickly agreed on was
that they didn't want to take peter
parker out of high school the idea of
peter experiencing the day-to-day events
of school life like school trips
homework a homecoming dance was such an
exciting and for marvel studios totally
different playground for ideas and
storytelling and if they ended up being
a multi-picture deal available they love
the notion of exploring the growing
pains of an adolescent spider-man over
numerous interconnected stories we also
learned separately that apparently amy
pascal started crying during this
meeting and told kevin feige to get the
hell out of her office at first but then
obviously it led to a pretty um um
mutually beneficial uh connected
universe of stories between sony and
marvel both of whom have really
benefited from this collaboration um so
when i read this quote mt i can't help
but wonder how this whole creative
strategy for this version of the peter
parker character might continue in
spider-man no way home this next movie
what do you think hmm so you mean like
specifically in the whole like uh we're
talking about peter as a like a student
as a young child like that narrative is
that what you mean yes trying to balance
uh
trying to balance being a student going
through his adolescence oh yeah i think
that this will manifest the most and we
see this in the trailer with a peter
parker's relationship with mj because
like this is the first relationship he's
had on screen
possibly in his whole life we don't know
i mean he's pretty handsome so maybe not
hopefully not um but you know i think
that he's going to find out and like
this is a big thing throughout you know
the rainy trilogies in the web trilogy
and just a spider-man staple in general
how hard it is to be spider-man and have
a girlfriend it's literally impossible
and in particular of how hard it is to
keep your your loved ones safe because
all these people are gunning after peter
parker people from the multiverse people
from his own universe like we still have
scorpion in prison who is gunning out
for uh peter parker um so yeah like it's
just it's i think it's that part of
being a kid that we're going to see and
like the whole no way home aspect could
have like a double meaning because
obviously it's no way home like no way
home to my home in my native dimension
but
i think it's probably going to be like
oh there's no way home to like the home
of my heart like the
mj like there's no way to to get to get
to mj because of all the stress all this
interdimensional stress and murder that
people try to just bring to my life so
yeah i don't know i think what do you
think um i think if you're looking at
like charting out these three movies
ahead of time you talk about these big
experiences that you go through as a
high school student uh your homecoming
dance uh school trips academic
decathlons uh to other cities to
washington dc um you talk about uh going
on school trips like in spider-man
homecoming you're able to maybe do a
trip abroad uh sometimes and it has to
be this like educational field trip uh
and you're pulled away from the field
trip and you're trying to like you know
hook up on it um uh but i think a big
part uh as you're leaving high school
your whole life becomes centered around
trying to get into the college you want
like i remember being a junior and
senior in high school and like going to
visit college campuses and feeling like
my whole life rests on whether or not i
can get into the right school uh that
has the right major i felt weirdly
pressured to pick a major when i was
still a senior in high school and being
like i don't know what i want to do with
the rest of my life but feeling like it
was make or break like if i don't get
into the right school my whole life is
gonna be over and looking back on it how
how silly that is like i didn't get into
my number one so i had my reach school i
had a couple safety schools but just
having to have that whole strategy like
i think that's gonna be a big part of
this movie like peter
uh is not gonna be able to get into the
college he wants
um like you know uh tony stark went to
mit and had that whole um program that
he gave them that whole scholarship
program uh and like williams is an mit
student i think a lot of this is gonna
be sent around mit uh or like empire
state or something like that and and
peter's gonna struggle to get into this
school uh because he's like you know a
criminal they're gonna look at his
you have a stellar academic record but
you also murdered mysterio and might be
a terrorist
i don't think we can let you in uh so i
think that's gonna be a big part of the
drama that like they were talking about
like things that kids go through i think
that's that might tell us some of the
stakes of this story that he's going to
be worried about whether he can get into
college oh yeah i don't think those sat
scores are going to do anything for him
after he murdered a guy i think
but he didn't of course we know he
didn't it's just what i mean do we i
mean he did say execute them all so i
think i mean he saw it on the internet
so it must be true
what's our the next question we want to
talk about mt well eric are the early
reviews for eternals accurately
reflecting the film because this is you
know this rotten tomatoes it's always
rotten tomato drama so like what do you
think you saw the movie i haven't seen
it i did see the movie and uh this week
we saw the rotten tomatoes score for
eternals come out the opening score that
will change over time but so far the
first round of critics reviews puts it
at an average of 72 percent fresh which
is how they do it well the critics
consensus reads they always write up a
little summary uh and it says an
ambitious superhero epic that soars more
often than it strains eternals takes the
mcu in intriguing and occasionally
confounding new directions
um now again that score probably will
not hold at 72 but so far that would
make eternals tied for the third lowest
mcu film rated by rotten tomatoes with
thor the dark world at 66
the 2008 incredible hulk film at 67
percent and then iron man 2 would also
be at 72 percent i think that tells us
more about how these uh tomato meter
scores
are pretty weighted in favor of the mcu
overall the fact that most of them are
above that is like whoa um that's pretty
generous
um now just for reference the sitelist
black panther as the best rated on their
site of the mcu it's at 96 followed by
end game and uh the first iron man both
at 94 percent and then thor ragnarok at
93 percent and then for the other 2021
releases black widow is currently listed
at 79
and chiang chi is listed at 92 percent
so shanxi i think is like number seven
um
now the question being is this a fair
assessment for eternals
no
that's what i'm thinking about because
like what you just ran though not no
offense to black widow black widow is a
fine film but for eternals to be lower
than black widow is kind of uh it's
flabbergasted me that doesn't make any
sense yeah that now is just i have seen
i have seen eternals and of course i've
seen black widow i've seen shang chi
eternals is definitely a better movie
than black widow
nothing against black widow but it is a
better movie than black widow uh now i
can see the debate once everyone sees
this movie i'm very curious to see what
the audience score this movie is and
what the social media reactions are um
i think the debate is gonna be is this
better than shang chi i could see
arguments for and against that i think
the action of shang chi
is is better than the action of eternals
uh but i think the the general world
building and the concepts and the the
kind of base story of eternals is really
cool and pretty novel pretty
groundbreaking
and i think i think a lot of people are
going to be won over by that and those
are going to be the people getting
invites on twitter with people
because i think
i really enjoyed it i just think it's
pretty by the by the ropes in terms of
like uh the story of just kind of an
origin story of a hero uh and i
perfectly enjoy that i don't have any
problems with that i just think when woo
is a more compelling character in the
shang chi film than shanxi is um and
eternals like ultimately you really do
relate with the struggle that the
eternals are going through the argument
they're having amongst themselves
watching them have to observe humanity
destroy itself so many times like that
is super heartbreaking and fascinating
as a story um so i think that's just yet
another example of how um the way rotten
tomatoes rates things and then boils
every review into a binary up or down
vote and uses that it's just not the
best assessment and we get into this
argument every time also i gotta say i'm
not gonna name names but some of the
people they include as as critics tomato
meter critics is insane to me that we
that these people get a vote like
this
dumbass who we all have to like look at
on twitter and they just make [ __ ] up
and they are clearly not journalists at
all
um
not all of them most of them are good
folks uh looking through the names i i'm
not gonna call anyone out i don't want
to start j jonah jameson on there uh
honestly yeah like the
the equivalent in our world of the mcu
jay jonah jameson infomores dumbasses
are included in some cases so
yep i'm not gonna name names again but
that's why when i see this number i'm
always just like whatever um anyway uh i
don't think it's a fair assessment i
don't think this is gonna be uh
in the top 10 for most people of mcu
movies uh but i don't think it deserves
to be in the bottom three at all and i
do think it was better than black widow
see when you when you read that quote in
the and it said uh occasionally
confounding i was just like okay so
these are people that are probably not
as invested into the mcu as we are
because like eternals was always going
to introduce these like really like
crazy out there cosmic stuff like these
cosmic elements that you know i think by
design you know human beings weren't
really meant to understand because like
the celestial they're supposed to be
these enigmatic you know cosmic people
so like i don't know what they mean by
occasionally confounding me you
definitely have a better idea than i do
but like i have an idea of what they
mean by it but like
i mean look there's a couple ways you
could see occasionally compounding and
i'm not gonna spoil anything but like
that either refers to people who like
have never read a comic book in their
lives or people who have never seen 2001
a space odyssey in their lives and if
either of those apply to you i don't
care what your opinion is about a marvel
cinematic universe movie
you should not be paid to write about
film if you have never read uh or you
should not be paid or invited to an
early screening for eternals if you've
never read a comic book in your life or
if you have not seen stanley kubrick's
2001 space odyssey it's like if you
haven't done either of those things if
you want to tweet about this movie have
an opinion on it go see it totally fine
but you should not be one of these
tomato meter critics all right all right
dude i
i'm so looking forward to the two
eternals because like it's so divisive
like i'm seeing all these reviews i'm
just like i really want to see this for
myself so i can like just form an
opinion for myself because it looks
beautiful yeah the soundtrack looks
amazing i think chloe zhao probably do a
fantastic job so i'm excited um i don't
know what these people are talking about
confounding my ass
my ass okay totally fine for opinions to
be mixed on this movie i totally expect
that but it is not in the bottom three
of the mcu by a long shot that's oh yeah
i think somewhere in the middle
somewhere i don't know where in the
middle just somewhere in the middle i
think it's definitely worth watching i
loved watching it oh it looks great i'm
very much looking forward to it
yeah
um all right well we will leave it there
for this episode of inside marvel now
next week our episode of inside marvel
will not be on wednesday we're going to
move it to the weekend so that it can be
an after show and reaction to give you
our
no spoiler thoughts or actually spoiler
thoughts we're not gonna worry about
spoilers because movies out there yeah
we'll have a spoiler warning at the
beginning but we're gonna go deeper into
some of the specific stuff that i don't
want to talk about yet um but yeah
you'll be able to see our fair
assessments uh and we'll all kind of
decide where this movie belongs in the
ranking for the mcu um now don't forget
to check out our many great merch
options at newarkstarsmerch.com follow
me at eavos follow mt mastertainment
follow new rockstars subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you for watching and we will see
you next week bye-bye
love you guys bye
you